i've hopefully given you a bit of a gut
feeling behind where the formula of
gibbs free energy comes from in this
video i want to do something a little
bit more rigorous and actually
i guess you could say derive the formula
so to do that let's just study two
systems that have the exact same change
in entropy and to depict that i'll i'll
get out the
our handy pv diagram
pv diagram we're going to do is going to
compare two systems one that's this
perfect reversible
system and one that's irreversible or
spontaneous system so and they're both
going to start here they're going to go
from this point on the pv diagram
to this point
right here and before we go into exactly
what they're doing i think it's a good
review of just kind of talking about
what an irreversible process and what a
reversible process really is an
irreversible process is this theoretical
thing where you have no friction
where
you're always so close to equilibrium
that you can always go backwards you're
you're you're you're always
you can kind of view that the reaction's
never really proceeding forward or
backwards although obviously it is
moving so it's a very uh it actually
doesn't really exist in nature but it's
a useful theoretical construct so let me
draw a little
so if this is a
i'll get the good old pistons out
so let's say this isn't i'll do it twice
so that's my irreversible piston and
this is my that'll be my reversible this
is my irreversible
let me draw them
okay let me label them
so this right here is going to be
reversible and this right here is going
to be irreversible irreversible or could
also be considered spontaneous
spontaneous
using the keyword that's going to matter
for gibbs free energy but all
spontaneous reactions are irreversible
so they're going to go from this state
to this state so in our reversible world
we have this
little
little the cap to our piston we have our
gas
in here
it's exerting some pressure and we'd
have as a bunch of pebbles we have a
bunch of pebbles out here
and we slowly remove the pebbles one by
one and as we remove the pebbles our
piston or this remote this movable
ceiling up here will move upwards
it'll move upwards so as we have the
pressure will push up but as we move up
we'll have lower and lower pressure
because the
the gases will bounce into the surface
less and we'll have a higher higher
volume so as we move each
infinitesimally small grain of sand and
we're going to do it super slow that
we're always infinitely close to
equilibrium we're going to move from
this state to this state and even better
this view that this is kind of the first
stage of our carnot cycle let's say in
either case we're on top of a
reservoir
so in either case both of these systems
are on top of this kind of infinite
reservoir that has a temperature
t1 and what that does is it kept keeps
the temperature constant so we're going
to travel along an isotherm because
normally if we were to remove these
things and the the the if we just
allowed to occur adiabatically we would
actually lose temperature we would
actually lose average kinetic energy as
work is done but in this case we have
this reservoir so heat is going to be
transferred to my system
heat is going to be transferred so let
me call that q r
right if this didn't if the reservoir
wasn't here if the reservoir wasn't here
our our temperature would go down but
since
since we do have the reservoir we'll
constantly be transferring heat so when
we've seen this this is just the first
stage of the carnot cycle we'll move
along an isotherm like this this is the
reversible case and the only reason why
we can even draw the state at every
point it here is because reversible
processes they're quasi-static they're
always infinitely close to equilibrium
and when we say reversible we're also
saying there's no friction between this
little piston and the cylinder that if
we put a grain of sand back it'll go
exactly to where it was before and no
energy was lost because there was no
heat of friction there so this is what
the graph of the reversible process
would look like now what is the graph of
the irreversible well actually no i
won't draw the graph but let's talk
about what the irreversible process is
going to be like
so it's going to look similar
it's going to look like that it's going
to have its gases there
but for the sake of an argument to get
from that state to that instead of
moving the pebbles one by one let's have
these big blocks
i have these big blocks and when i
remove one of these big blocks i go from
that state to that state but it
obviously throws all hell breaks loose
so i'm not really defined in this in
between state but i definitely go from
that state to that state once i go back
to equilibrium now the other key thing
in the irreversible process is that and
every real process in our world is
irreversible is that you're going to
have friction here
you're going to have friction here as
this moves up it's going to rub against
the side of the container and generate
heat of friction
heat of friction so let me call that
so let me ask you a question
if in this case
q sub r had to be added to the system to
maintain its temperature
does what's going to be the q
what's going to be the q
sub irreversible here how much has to be
added to this system in order to keep it
at the constant temperature t1
will have to be more or less than what
was added to the reversible system well
this guy as this piston as this piston
moves up he's generating some of his own
heat so if this was an adiabatic process
he wouldn't lose as much temperature as
this guy would so he's he's going to
need less heat from the reservoir in
order to maintain his temperature at t1
in order to get to this point on the
isotherm remember this irreversible
process we don't know what happens over
here he might be traveling on some crazy
path in fact we can't even define the
path because it goes out of equilibrium
so it's going to be some crazy thing but
we know it pops back on the pv diagram
right there but because it's generating
some of its own heat from the friction
it's going to need less heat from the
reservoir so let me write that down
the heat absorbed by the reversible
process is going to be greater than the
heat absorbed by the irreversible
process
and that's because the irreversible
process is generating friction
fair enough now what is the change in
entropy for both systems well they both
started here and they both ended here
and entropy is a state variable so the
change in entropy
the change in entropy for the reversible
process is going to be equal to the
change in entropy
is going to be equal to the change in
entropy for the
entropy for the irreversible process
they're both going from there to there
now what is the total and obviously the
entropy has changed we're going from one
state to another state and the entropy
well i won't go too much into it but
let's ask another question what is the
total change in entropy of the universe
for the reversible process
so the for the universe so that's going
to be our universe here is the reservoir
in our system so let me write here
reversible i don't want to run out of
space let me see i'll do a different
color so this is the reversible process
so change in entropy of the universe is
equal to the change in entropy of our
reversible process
plus
the change in entropy
of well i already use r for reversible
so you know let's call it the reserve
well the first three letters are the
same so let me call it of the of of our
environment
right and in the reversible process the
change
in entropy of our reversible process is
the heat added for our reversible
process
and we can use this definition because
it is a reversible process
it's that over t1
and then what's the change in entropy of
our environment well it's giving away q
sub r right so it has it's it's heat
absorbed as minus q sub r and of course
it's at a constant temperature it is a
it is a heat reservoir so it's at t1
so it equals
zero
equals zero interesting so that well i
mean actually i should take a little
side note here that the change in
entropy of the universe for a reversible
process is zero
and actually that should make a lot of
intuitive sense because the whole point
of a reversible process is you could go
in this direction
or you could go in that direction it's
always so close to equilibrium you can
move in either direction and if the
entropy was greater than zero in one
direction it would have to be less than
zero in the other direction so it
wouldn't be able to go in the other
direction by the second law of
thermodynamics so it actually makes
sense that the entropy the of the
universe the change in entropy of the
universe not just of the system when a
reversible process occurs is zero
let's see if we can relate that to the
irreversible process
so if i wanted to figure out the change
in entropy of the irreversible process
what's the change in entropy of the
irreversible process
and then let me say let me subtract from
that the heat
the heat that was taken away from the
reservoir from the irreversible process
q
ir and of course all of this over
t1
what is this going to be equal to as i
guess in relation to zero remember this
is an irreversible spontaneous process
well this value we it's going the
irreversible process is starting here
and going there so it's change in delta
s is the exact same thing as that it's
the change in delta s is the same as the
reversible process so these two things
are equivalent
now i just told you that since there's
some heat of friction this guy has to
take in less
less heat from the reservoir than this
guy so if this and i wrote it here let
me clean this thing up a little bit i
wrote it right here
q sub ir the heat that the irreversible
process has to take from the reservoir
because generating its own heat from
friction is less than the heat from the
reversible process so this number right
here is less than this number here
or
this you could view it this way this
number here was equal to this
so this number here is going to be less
than this so this has to be
this has to be
greater than
0 for the reversible process sorry for
the irreversible
irreversible spontaneous
spontaneous process
now let's just do a little bit of
mathematics
so this is the heat that was essentially
given to the irreversible system and
it's a minus here because this is the
term it's kind of taken away from the
actual reservoir so let's just do a
little bit of of let's multiply all
sides of this equation by t1
and we get t1
times delta s of the irreversible
process
minus
q
of the irreversible process is greater
than 0.
now i well
let's just so what what is this how can
we say this if we if we wanted to let's
actually let's just multiply both sides
of this by negative 1. and remember this
is true for any irreversible spontaneous
process if you multiply both sides of
this by negative 1 you get this the heat
added to the irreversible process
minus t times delta s
of the irreversible process is going to
be less than zero
that this is true for any irreversible
spontaneous process
and at this point this should look
reasonably familiar to you
when we wrote our gibbs free energy
formula we said change in g
change in g is equal to delta h
minus t times delta s and we said that
if this is
less than 0 then we have a spontaneous
process
but these two and this all makes sense
because these two are equivalent to each
other what's the only difference here
here we wrote heat added to the system
here we wrote change in enthalpy and
i've done three or four videos right now
where i say that change in enthalpy
is equal to the heat added to a system
as long as
as long as we're dealing with a constant
pressure system
constant pressure so if we get this
result just by comparing irreversible to
reversible system and this is true for
all irreversible spontaneous
processes and then if we assume that
we're dealing with a constant pressure
system so you can kind of forget a
little bit of what i just drew because
we know that this is true when we assume
constant pressure then we get to this
and then we know that if something is
spontaneous then this right here must be
less than zero so hopefully you found
that a little bit interesting actually
i'll i'll do one more one more point
here this kind of gels with the idea
that any spontaneous
with the second law of thermodynamics
that tells us that if for any
spontaneous process delta s
is going to be greater than or equal or
well for any spontaneous process it's
going to be greater than zero because
although this right here it isn't the
formal definition of entropy uh for for
because we're not dealing with a
reversible process here you can kind of
think of it that way and so it at least
on an intuitive level it kind of gets
you there that where we have delta s
greater than zero and i won't fixate on
that too much because i want to what i
did earlier in the video is more
rigorous than what i'm heading to right
now so hopefully that gives you a sense
that gives you a sense of where you can
get to the gibbs free energy formula and
how it drives spontaneous reactions from
just our basic understanding of what
reversible and irreversible processes
are and how they relate to entropy and
heat exchange and enthalpy